it's super clever i mean the argument is
completely circular right they just say
you're a racist and you say well but you
have no evidence in my races and they
say well you don't even recognize your
own racism you say well then
how am i racist they say because you're
complicit in a system of racism you say
right but the system
isn't isn't racist like you can't point
to something that's written no but it
results in racial inequality
and therefore it is a racist system and
therefore you are complicit in the
system and therefore you're a racist
and you say okay well but all systems
perpetuate racial inequality
by even saying that you're demonstrating
your white fragility which means you're
a racist right like
this is basic salem witch trial if you
sink then you're innocent and if you
float then you're a witch
[Music]
so we've sort of talked about this a
little bit before but do you think there
is a
fundamental reason for that that there
is a fundamental reason
that underlies the philosophy of someone
who broadly is on the left
versus on the right that why people on
the right are willing to do it if i put
someone
on the left on my show i put marianne
williamson on i put on andrew yang tulsi
gabbard
all the people on the right virtually
who disagree with them say hey you know
i disagree with her and him on this and
that and the other thing but it's glad
yeah i'm glad you had the conversation
if i put someone if i put you on or
praygron the lefties go bananas i'm i'm
endorsing white supremacy and
because i think that for the left and
there are many liberals who buy into
this
all all human relations are power
relations right you saw this in sort of
ezra klein's response to mad iglesias
right how did i end up on the same side
as
matt iglesias man i thought the ralph
wiggum of the internet right like how
how has this happened but matt iglesias
had the temerity to sign that letter and
then ezra klein was like there are a lot
of people who stand up for the for free
speech who are really doing this because
it's a way of gaining power and for a
lot of people this is on the left this
is how they think of things right all
human relationships are power dynamics
there are no
big principles that we all share like
freedom of speech matters that's just a
bunch of people who are seeking to use
the principle of freedom of speech
as a weapon in order to reenact the
hierarchy in order to preserve the
hierarchy and this argument you see
being made more and more by folks on the
left which is that rights are not
actually universal principles that we
all should hold to rights are just a way
for me to shut you up while i'm still
speaking
right and that's and i think that the
the liberal
left has been somewhat warm to that
argument for for a while at least warm
enough that they were willing to hear it
and they just didn't see it turning on
them at any point the left moves so far
so fast that the liberals were like we
were with you up until the point where
you started canceling us
and then we realized oh wait that was a
that was a bad mistake right iglesias
was one of the guys who's like cheering
on there's no cancel culture cancel the
cancellation doesn't exist
and then the and then it came for him
and he was like uh
this is bad right guys it's like yes
it's bad well yes
thank you for recognizing it is bad do
you love seeing that now where
there's this move by them now aoc is
doing this and a bunch of other people
to completely tell us that cancel
culture it doesn't even exist
it doesn't exist your imagination yeah
figments of your when she's not
explaining that
that people are shooting each other in
the inner city for bread for bread right
which is
that that's why you should one year old
playground is because they're hungry
that's what i do when i'm hungry you
know
i say to my wife are we out of cereal
she says yes and i immediately go and
shoot somebody in the face
that's that's the way i deal with my own
personal hanger
but but when she's not saying that sort
of stuff this is
becoming a very popular notion on the
left which is that all america is a
group of people who are dispossessed
and the people who are victimizers and
any principle
that exists in the system that is the
victimizing system again this goes back
to the the kennedy point or the robin
d'angelo point
any aspect of that system is inherently
bad and reinforces a power hierarchy and
so you must
remove those systems of power in order
to allow the dispossessed to claim their
full share of the earth you're a sci-fi
guy do you sort of admire
the beauty of their evil you know what i
mean like
really at this level like to create a
system that that proves itself
yeah in and of itself is the proof like
there's a certain beauty to that oh it
happens
it's super clever i mean the argument is
completely circular right they just say
you're a racist and you say well but you
have no evidence in my racism they say
well you don't even recognize your own
racism you say well then
how am i racist they said because you're
complicit in a system of racism say
right but the system
isn't isn't racist like you can't point
to something that's written no but it
results
in racial inequality and therefore it is
a racist system and therefore you are
complicit in the system and therefore
you're a racist
and you say okay well but all systems
perpetuate racial inequality
by even saying that you're demonstrating
your white fragility which means you're
a racist right like
this is basic salem witch trial if you
sink then you're in a sense and if you
float then you're a witch
yeah all right so a lot of this actually
is very much the point of the book so
just quickly before we fully go into
that uh just let's just do covid quickly
sure like where the hell are we at in
this let's just talk about california
for a second
we just in the last couple days went
into another freaking lockdown it's
beautiful outside
i don't i i'm not sure what the beach
situation is whether we can go there but
i know i can't go to a restaurant
it's like what the hell is going on here
at this point what do you think is
honestly happening at this so i think
what's honestly happening is that you
have
a deadly disease that has probably
somewhere between a
two times and six times deadly as an
effect
as the flu it's somewhere between 0.2
and 0.6 uh
infection fatality rate uh and that's
dangerous and it's very very infectious
and
all of that is true the whole point of
flattening the curve was to prevent the
overwhelming of the healthcare system
we are not seeing the healthcare system
being overwhelmed right now and so the
idea that the only tactic that is
available is full-scale lockdown
i think is is not backed by evidence i
am also growing extraordinarily tired
of people shouting that they are on the
side of science while variously changing
their opinion literally every 15 seconds
so when masks are bad
now masks are good protests are bad with
anti-lockdown protests now
protests are good and this woke virus
spares you so long as you're kneeling
for george floyd right
i mean think how bananas that is it's
crazy it's utterly nuts i mean that that
was
that was mind-bogglingly incredible and
blazio this week said that in effect you
are allowed to protest because racism is
so systemic and profoundly evil
that somehow it supersedes the deadly
virus
everyone else couple orthodox jews
playing in a park in brooklyn we got a
problem it's a seriously woke virus i
mean good for colin kaepernick who
should win the nobel peace prize as well
as the nobel prize in biology because
kneeling it turns out actually cures
coronavirus which is pretty awesome when
you think about it
but it but it's yeah i think that there
have been a bunch of false binaries that
have been set up and those false
binaries are things like it's either
total lockdown or total openness
it annoys me when people on the right
treat mask wearing as though it's like a
virtue signal and it annoys me on the
left when people treat mask wearing as
though it's an incredible virtue signal
you're an evil evil person
if you're not wearing a mask when you go
to sleep at night and you're a better
person if you wear a mask
and on the and on the right there are
people for sure who are like well i'm
not wearing a mask under any
circumstance it's a violation of my
freedoms and all this kind of like look
just
when you're in a popular when you're in
a populated area with a lot of other
people
wear a mask it didn't that bad like you
should do it because you don't want
other people to get sick it's
like that's the best we can do at this
point in time with that said the idea
that we're going to full scale lock down
the entire american economy
or that we are going to leave children
out of school for the next year
because of covet like that seems
patently insane to me i mean
the reason it seems patently insane is
because the data are pretty murky on a
lot of
issues they're absolutely not murky on
the risk to children there is so little
risk to children if you're under the age
of 20 you have a better chance of dying
from the flu than you'd have covered i
mean that's just straight stat
and what that means is that maybe we can
come up with some creative solutions
where parents actually have
a place where their kids can go for
schooling so and my friend john padhor
is over a commentary magazine i thought
he had a good idea he said why don't you
keep the schools open
and then you have a bunch of 20 year old
proctors and then you have the teachers
zoom in why is it the teacher has to
zoom to all the kids at home right why
don't they why don't you just
do it at school right that seems like a
fairly decent
idea um but the the the incentive
structure is created
yeah for politicians to lock down
because the more sternly you treat the
virus the better
the media are going to treat you right
the more virtuous you are right exactly
and this is how you see andrew cuomo who
is a garbage cheap of a governor in this
whole time and who now
creates magical posters tributes to
himself with literally a curve that
represents the number of dead bodies
in his state right being treated as
though he was great at this when his
death rate is like eight or nine times
that of florida where ronda sanchez is
the font of all evil and greg abbott in
texas
it's like 11 or 12 times the death rate
in texas like
this none of the media coverage makes
sense the media there are a bunch of
issues here the politics of it makes no
sense the media coverage of it makes
some sense but it's a really ugly sense
because the politics have overwhelmed
the data
and then on a data level there's just a
lot we we actually don't know
at this point right we don't know
whether there's such a thing as t-cell
immunity that's
been one of the theories that herd
immunity actually may start to kick in
as low as 20 percent is a theory from
sweden
it could be at 60 uh we don't know
whether this thing is
how far away you have to be from
somebody they say six feet but the who
was saying a meter until five minutes
ago
by the way technically my guy's measured
we're seven feet away oh yeah no and i
insisted on that like i'm a person who's
taking this very seriously right i mean
like i
i've been taking it seriously i have 65
year old parents so i'm not on the
let's be skeptical of all of this stuff
but the idea that like it's going to
wipe out vast swaths of the american
public and that
and that it's the most dangerous thing
that has ever existed on planet earth
and that we have to shut down the
economy
odd infant item here's the problem has
anyone ever actually done
on the on the lockdown side any analysis
of what the costs are on the other side
all i hear is if you mention those costs
then you're bad and you'll go back into
being right
and that's that's insane like these are
public policy decisions and we should
obviously be having conversations about
how to protect the most vulnerable and
also
how to trans people back in to work i
mean i've been saying for a long time
that it may end up being
that the way that we end up moving
forward is what
one i think was hebrew university where
tel aviv university scientists suggested
was controlled avalanche the idea was
if you're most vulnerable you stay home
and we figure out ways to protect you
and if you're less vulnerable then you
go out and if you get it you get it and
then you're
one person closer to hurt immunity that
may be effectively
de facto what we're seeing anyway right
because this is how let's be real about
this if you're 20 this is kind of how
you're treating it then this is where
they're going to say you want to kill
people
right that's what last time you were
here you were here for my book launch
and i wrote the video you were the
number one trend on twitter
because you said we're going to have to
deal with some level of death it's a
problem we don't want to but that's just
reality
and then they came after you and said no
no no one should die in our perfect
right
i made the i made the very pure and
obvious which everyone
everyone understands the argument i was
making which is that if you're looking
at days of life versus just lives lost
that is a different calculation and it
is done by actuaries every single day
the federal government has actuaries
that do this on every single policy
but again the the media narrative is is
very easy here
if you don't mirror the policies they
want then you're you're a grandma killer
who wants to murder
your own grandma it doesn't matter that
i'm taking all sorts of extraordinary
you know measures in order to protect my
own parents on this thing if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist all
right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell